hello welcome back to games to our
continuing coverage of e3 2015 as we
know every e3 is full of surprises
yesterday had no shortage of them and
one of the best ones we saw on the
Microsoft stage was a new game from the
one and only Keiji Inafune a recore and
I'm delighted to be joined by unified
Assad nice to meet you nice to meet you
mark from Harbinger as well and here on
kyoko you're gonna be interpreting for
mr. Fuji thank you so much for coming on
and talking to us today
and this is a game that I think sparked
a lot of people's interest obviously we
know the mighty number 9 is continuing
so really fascinating to see that
another triple a game room from mr. foon
they got there come on the scale
Cantonese okay Susan I don't worry toe
no cara de que no sick icons and I could
tell her I soon our game what could
screw type you go today and of course is
ink on a jute or Mac could too you know
robot Totoro usually toka Sakuni
a robot arooga high-tech 32 cars through
Yona I know gene do you know me right
okay so we took our money consciousness
Arianna so he gave me an afternoon there
are no matter escena who noir don't know
so my hope is that with this brand new
title recur that I can show you a
completely different dimension of my
world you know Funes world and by that
what I mean is that you know just from
looking at the trailer you might think
oh wow combat heavy and it's gonna be
all action-adventure but there's layers
and layers that are going into this game
one being the main character here jewel
and her relationship that she will
hopefully build her over time with
companions such as Mac here so it's a
world fill fold with combat but also
friendship love there's a lot of themes
that are really building up the story
at a very high level at a very sort of
conceptual level the backdrop is set at
a time when you know there may be only a
few human survivors and what the world's
gonna be like at that time I'm
interested to know you've been involved
in dead of course games like that rising
Lost Planet and all of these wonderful
games to come out on the Xbox console
and obviously we knew you were working
on mighty number 9 but how long has this
been in development or did you sign it
kinda chocolate Susannah Korea no
julianka Gazoo rainbow yeah teratoma SK
don't turn a Machado is shawni conga
negara yeah today an ocarina torus or
relationship tomorrow
Microsoft oh no member toe Sugoi co-main
me Tony Hana she updates good through
there it's work we do
so it's been about 14 months ok owning
all the months it's been about 14 months
but it's been a very close collaborative
project with armature as well as
Microsoft and so it's hard to believe
that you know it's only been 14 months
because of the tightness and the
closeness of the relationship that we
built here but yeah in a a little over a
year um your games are always full of
wonderful characters tell us something
about these characters and especially
the I guess the the creature what how
many times will the creature be changing
form and on what are we looking at in
this blue ball is that the creatures
soul is it the creatures essence come on
that's they talk Cooney is shown here
echo no one sure you know robotium otama
she know you mean descoteaux you must
say kikuno much inertia study choreo
giacconi bits no nato both Tony Himiko
mutapa you sono ato
kudasai no moto moto fi da gah gah gah
Araki de carne Seca Co motifs Naruto
corny
Sakuni do you karate tae Kuk akuto
tsunami chairman Bartow yo ro Kangin
Agora they design a boom or cerini uh
today's
Oh scam or Nihonjin economy doc is an
actor America Nemecek I do demo
chronometer Ginga chorus subarashii
tomodea design Lee is Shirley Kangana se
Yoon AE people to Tori below Maserati
it's good to go out Tori makisu boom do
you know you know it's Kate a good you
know go to idea Roboto
so at the origin of this recore title
project is the core and the Cole the
core as you said is really representing
the soul this creature the sphere that
you see here and so it's got its own
sort of personality it's got its own
character to it and what I think
together with our mature based on that
core idea of really taking the value and
the importance of the core adding in
flavours adding layers and constructing
something that not just a specific type
of genre fans or not just a specific
type of you know Japanese game fans or
Western audience members can enjoy
something that hopefully will speak on a
global level Universal sort of language
and that's the center of everything is
at the core hopefully will be something
that can be interpreted by gamers around
the world and Mark you must be a fan of
his previous work what's it like working
what's it like for you guys taking on
this project and then what what sort of
form is it out there because obviously
14 months isn't very long time at all
and from what we've seen from the
trailer and that is this could be a very
multiple different types of games so
what is what does it look like at the
moment yeah I mean we the way concept in
our mature work is that in the fullness
ons group really kind of gives us a high
level structure and ideas like the core
everything kind of filtering back into
the essence of what are these characters
and how in every aspect of the game that
they touched on that concept and very
early on we kind of talked about what
the game would be like you know we had
very early with
a third-person action-adventure game yes
so it wasn't just a platformer it just
was on a combat game it was a really
nice mix and blend of the two
exploration was a very big part of it
and on top of those things how can this
aspect of these characters and these
cores filter into every part of the game
so that people are constantly reminded
about the themes about the core and
you're immediately drawn to these
characters but you know Mack this
character is the core but he's
identified as the dog right now you see
in the video he quickly is put into a
different form yeah and you're always
gonna have the opportunity to do
anything you want and customize them any
way you will like but there's going to
be certain situations like that one
where Mac basically sacrifices himself
for the character and those are
situations that you're having to deal
with and how do you adjust your gameplay
for that awesome obviously we're very
far away from seeing this game I'm
assuming and in store shelves or
digitally when will we see more about
recore shirokova ticket on the show so
now onto a moto moto did I miss it I see
a toe-mah-toe miss a removal out of this
cat or a Congo a pyro arrow go do not
miss it taken again I toe motor the
cocoa pepper chili cockatoo fry the name
oh no don't don't miss it a Kirito bone
there are oxidized a bottle
so obviously this week at e3 you're only
seeing a very small slice yes a glimpse
of what to look forward to in the world
of recore I'm confident the team is
confident that hopefully within the next
few months you will be able to show to
talk about it a lot more awesome mark go
go into furnace on pleasure to thank you
so much for spending time with us on the
game on stage I really can't wait to see
more about recore thank you so much
thank you very much for watching we're
still going alive here on the GameSpot
stage stay tuned I'm rebirth from
Microsoft's gonna be back in just a
little bit he might bring his other
controller with him and I will probably
ask him what he thought
about all the conferences here at e3 so
stay tuned look back in a second